voilà alors malgré ce succès tiao vous
êtes toujours très réservé très fait
timide comme ça vous avez un peu sûr de
vous ouais mais pas tant que ça quand
même en sais ce qui m'attend ce qui me
ce qui m'impressionne c'est la télé pour
moi ce que c'est comme une loupe
ouais alors ça me fait très bizarre
d'être là je regarde l'émission depuis
des années j'étais jamais vu merci pour
l'invitation
et c'est vrai que c'est un singe endroit
où je ne suis pas très à l'aise
faites suer un musicien donc mon truc
c'est d'être en studio d'essayer de
faire des bonnes sources elle voilà
c'est ça mon métier après d'aller en
parler je trouve ça vachement difficile
mais je vais faire de mon mieux ce soir
est julien d'accueil comme la pierre
qu'elle a à z en famille non je me
disais que c'était peut-être dû etienne
à une prime enfance c'est assez
chaotique quand même un oui sûrement
vous êtes né le 14 janvier 58 et le
capricorne qui a pris commande comme moi
oui oui c'est vrai oui moi je trouve
beaucoup d'affinités avec d'autres
capricorne c'est ainsi une pas très pas
très drôle quoi c'est des gens qui sont
assez laborieux à ses scrupules c'est
pas très gai mais bon ça c'est la
vitrine vitrine qui est un peu pratique
d'ailleurs un sens mais d'être un peu
seul
ça permet d'être un peu plus tard et ont
au contraire c'est pierrot wii accueille
bac
obligé de dire que c'est la violence
était un sentir mon bidon c'est à un ami
hollandais voilà osé pas très bien dans
le capricorne
vous êtes né à oran en algérie et pas du
tout à rennes comme disait vovo
biographie au départ au départ vous
aviez pas corriger quoi qu'on les bio
disait oui je m'en foutais un peu je
pensais pas que ça durerait aussi
longtemps mais alors vous êtes né à oran
votre père était militaire il était
appelé c'était la guerre d'algérie votre
mère était chimiste et votre mère
manière jamais été soumis avant puis a
commencé
avec quoi je fais ton était femme au
foyer comme comme quoi ce nom mais comme
mon père comme mon père est parti en
fait elle a trouvé un un boulot comme
secrétaire dans une boîte de produits
chimiques ne l'a jamais technique du
tout à la cale à mon nom c'était autre
chose y'a comme un lien avec la chimie
oui mais un peu lointain quand même
c'était pas les mêmes c'est pas le
flâneur et votre mère était fan d'elvis
ah ouais ouais ça j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir des parents très fan de musique
donc à la base mon père jouait de la
trompette simple c'est un fan de musique
achetée beaucoup de disques donc j'ai eu
une base musique très très très tôt à la
maison c'est vrai qu'à l'âge de 3 ans
vous connaissez déjà des chansons par
coeur
oui j'avais une vie une mémoire visuelle
je montre l ai dit ce que je voulais un
que je voulais écouter donc tout
commence bien et là votre père abandonne
la famille dans des circonstances assez
bizarre il est parti chercher des
cigarettes
en fait comme dans la chanson dans cet
immeuble un peu plus un peu plus épais
que ce à quoi parce que c'était en fait
ça ressemble à une trahison une vraie
trahison parce que parce qu'en fait il
l'est il a laissé donc ses enfants pour
mes soeurs et moi et ma mère en algérie
qui était vraiment en plein cauchemar
que c'était vraiment très dangereux à ce
moment là et lui a demandé le livret de
famille pour pouvoir se barrer quoi en
faisant passer une autre femme pour ça
pour sa femme
c'est un truc est quand même là c'est le
top niveau de 2,2 du rien à quoi et de
la trahison et est donc voilà vous
l'avez jamais enlever votre père si je
les revues quand j'ai commencé quand
j'ai commencé à chanter un jour il fine
c'est un truc télé parce qu'en fait en
fait il s'est présenté à l'olympia quand
ça a commencé à marcher pour moi et il
s'est présenté comme étant mon père avec
sa nouvelle famille
et donc on est venu me dire ça juste
avant de monter sur scène pour moi c'est
un concert terrible quoi je savais qu'il
allait peut-être voir ma mère est oui
s'était pas vu depuis des années c'était
quand même très très fin très très chaud
quoi et j'ai refusé ensuite qu'ils
viennent me voir dans dans la loge et
c'est un truc que j'ai toujours regretté
enfin j'ai vraiment culpabiliser mais à
ce prix c'est difficile vous l'avez
jamais vue après bon après j'ai lancé un
appel parce qu'il ya non non non non
jaloux vont se dire qu'on fait c'est de
moi c'est dur ça va être plus dur c'est
la vie oui oui la vie bien sûr cela
votre père était assez fortunés mais
évidemment quand il s'en va votre mère
se retrouve avec trois gosses et et sans
argent
et puis c'était la guerre quoi c'était
la guerre d'algérie avec loin du mad
donc s'ils étaient la mort omniprésente
vous dites on pouvait pas passer devant
les semaines parce qu'on a peur de
prendre des balles quoi si elle est
passée sous les fenêtres et on rentre et
il est arrivé de rentrer de l'école et
de trouveront des macchabées voilà des
mecs avec la cervelle vision assez
c'est traumatisante et puis il ya plein
de choses assez traumatisant dans les
usages en effet une chanson qui
s'appelle de bien jolies flammes
une chanson que j'ai que j'ai dit à ma
mère qui était vraiment tout seul pour
nous défendre mais met ensuite en bon ça
c'est le côté le que de faire un peu oui
il y avait il y avait 100 sécher et et
puis y avait aussi les grands parents
parce que vous viviez chez chez vos
grands parents qui avaient une échoppe
mib a remis épicerie au bord de la mer
là il y avait un jukebox et même les
grandes années voilà et voilà et c'est
là que etienne daho dans ce jukebox dans
cette période absolument troublé et
tragique
vous avez découvert sylvie vartan
françoise hardy des gens avec remettre
tous les yéyés puis enfin les tubes de
l'époque donc là il vraiment un truc
magique ouais c'est pour ça qu'avec le
temps je pense que j'ai une affection
toute particulière cette période parce
que c'est vraiment un moment qui est un
joli moment pour moi parce qu'entre
temps ça que j'avais j'étais en pension
l'âge de 4 ans était tout petit et mon
angoisse était de quand j'entraîne
week-end en bus qui est personnes
c'était terrible pour moi
fast une angoisse quoi donc là ce coin
de ce ce moment jukebox musique soleil
ça c'est un intrus dans bien c'est la
musique qui me l'a sorti de tout ça
parce qu'ensuite vos grandes soeurs vous
font découvrir la motown
les groupes anglais des années 60 les
beatles et puis vous découvrez tout seul
les rendrai x les doors et puis un jour
à l'âge de 15 ans chez un soldeur vous
tombez sur ce disque était à la banane
oui le velvet vingtaine alors ça change
m a fait découvrir le rock ce disque oui
pis et ça ça que c'était sûr que j'ai
commencé à devenir obsessionnel certains
disquaires je vis la musique d'une
manière obsessionnelle
car je peux écouter indices pendant deux
ans et si j'aime un artiste il faut que
j'achète tous que j'ai tous les bio les
dvd c'est un jeu fin c'est vraiment il
faut que je maîtrise le sujet en passer
un autre c'est ça le truc à kabrikha
siliana revient à un autre s'il ya
effectivement le velvet underground mais
aussi les pink floyd à l'époque de syd
barrett le bord
pink floyd c'est quand même fou wes et
puis il y aussi beaucoup beaucoup mais
ça c'est aussi des deux mondes en
français c'est brian wilson des beach
boys pour moi c'est vraiment très très
bien cet album surfing safari ouais moi
c'est vraiment c'est tout le c'est
vraiment ça c'est toute la magie de
l'enfance quoi vous avez trouvé comment
l'album de brian wilson qui est qu'ils
sortiraient je préfère l'original ray
oui c'est un peu décevant mais par
contre je veux de la pire est devant le
est le plus beau concert j'ai reçu voilà
et puis ensuite on va pas raconter toute
la vie détiennent là où il devient
l'idole des jeunes à son tour un ça a
été énorme et ça l'est toujours
d'ailleurs c'est le révolutionne d'éden
comme quand il arriverait mais c'était
pop 1 c'était c'était frais sa musique
est alors un jour au milieu de cette
gloire la lumière que vous voyez depuis
que vous êtes tout petit en fermant les
yeux
cette lumière s'éteint oui c'est très
lui en fait la disparition avec la
disparition mon père a été comme une
bombe à retardement au fait c'est un
moment je travaille beaucoup je pars je
pensais régler un peu mes problèmes en
accumulant les shows en bout de cinq ans
en travaillant et saint céran des
rustines quoi en plus la musique était
ma passion vraiment j'ai beaucoup bossé
pour moi ça a très bien marché c'était
génial
c'était un cadeau absolument incroyable
mais travailler avec les autres si c'est
à dire des gens que j'ai que dont
j'étais fan quand j'étais adolescent que
d'un coup venait me demander de
travailler avec eux c'était quand même
dément et et puis un jour c'est vrai que
j'ai eu il ya eu un truc de surmenage
cela veut dire un planning qui était
prêt pour les gagnants qui venait c'est
un peu ça c'est dans la tête mais je
pensais j'étais superman un an plus
comme chien fait tard je dormais 14
secondes par nuit je veux c'est beaucoup
je travaille beaucoup et puis à un
moment bon ben voilà c'est le cas c'est
une sensation de bouffe quoi vous avez
le sentiment que le meilleur est
derrière vous ouais et puis surtout j'ai
vraiment choisi ce métier parce que
j'aime la musique et parce que j'ai
envie d'en faire et au bout d'un moment
c'est un métier où on est beaucoup à
représentation beaucoup plus qu'en
création ça ça me manque vraiment donc
j'ai essayé de depuis en tout cas décès
de deux de faire un équilibre entre la
création et puis côté vrp là mais ce qui
est incroyable c'est qu'à ce moment là
vous avez le sentiment qu'il faut mourir
pour renaître
quoique une nouvelle doit commencer et
c'est l'époque où commence à courir la
rumeur de votre mort c'est une
coïncidence absolument pas mieux tomber
ah oui le bruit les cris le nord non
mais c'est vrai et c'est à ce moment là
qu'on a commencé à dire il est mort il
est mort du sida à l'hôpital de rennes
et quand vous croisez des gens et vous
d'isabella toi je crois que c'était mort
c'est arrivé a avoué apple ma carte
risque pas mal remarque êtes géniaux 6
adjani ou si oui
non mais c'est sinon c'est fou c'est
l'histoire mais vous avez comme adjani
si vous n'êtes pas allé à la télé pour
dire regardez je vais bien mais je
t'offre un bon camp adjani la fst 83
donc c'était encore plus sensible
c'était vraiment la lèvre moi ce que je
peux en 92 13 là ça commençait ce que
j'ai
j'ai fait un album qui s'appelle urgence
enfin j'étais à la base cet album dont
les fonds ont été reversés à l'institut
pasteur pour le sida et je pense qu'à ce
moment là des gens pensaient que j'étais
un peu plus impliqué que ce que je
voulais dire et ça a commencé en choisit
pour cela il n'ya même connerie sur moi
ça va durer trente secondes et puis ça
va ça va disparaître et donc à ce moment
j'ai habité à londres j'ai pas vraiment
je n'ai pas vraiment fait gaffe ça me
paraissait pas très important je suis je
vais faire un bon disque
voilà ça va durer quatre secondes à et
puis ça s'est vraiment incrusté enquête
et c'est vraiment le truc dont je peux
plus me débarrasser serre que c'était
pas dur au moment où j'étais à londres
finalement c'est quand je suis rentré
j'avais un dix sous le bras que
j'adorais que
vraiment j'avais l'impression de m'être
cassé le cul avant d'avoir fait un beau
disque et de ça et on ne parlait que de
ça j'ai l'impression laissée par les
plus d'un truc qui n'était pas la
réalité que tu que je venais de faire et
ça ça me rendait un peu dingue les gens
là vous voyez il cherchait sur votre
visage les stigmates de la maladie il y
avait celle qui disait mieux je vois
bien qu'il est malade il y ceux qui
était allés à son enterrement ça qu'à
l'époque on croisait régulièrement des
secours il était allé à l'enterrement
mme dao
ouais vraiment dans la rue ils disaient
ah bah faudrait savoir
c'est un cauchemar c'est terrible oui
vous vous prenez en pleine gueule à
l'annoncé plus tu veux ça tape aussi
dans ta taper dans mes angoisses c'est
vrai que ce que tu racontes et de
soleure vraiment j'ai toujours eu dans
une angoisse de mort parce que c'est
quelque chose qui était très très
présent depuis tout petit quoi donc
voilà ça tapait direct dans et depuis
c'est bien depuis j'ai plus peur depuis
que c'est fini et puis en même temps
être honnête etienne la psychanalyse
vous a aidé aussi beaucoup bien sûr bien
sûr heureusement aussi on va sortir la
tête hors de l'eau mais c'est à dire que
c'est un moment où j'ai pété les plombs
et en plus il ya eu ce truc là c'est
quand même je n'ai pas besoin de ça quoi
mais mais ça a été bien ça m'a permis de
d'envisager autre chose et tout ça a un
sens c'est aussi ne sais pas c'est pas
un truc ya pas de sens qui m'a laissé un
vrai un vrai sens soit permis aux plus
de vraiment décider de ce que je voulais
faire décider de comment allait être ma
vie ma carrière et et de ne pas me
laisser salir dirigé par autre chose
voilà je fais ce que j'aime c'est arrivé
à un point où j'aime ce que je fais
j'aime ma place tout ça c'est un sens je
suis très heureux quoi c'est peut-être
maintenant qu'il faut mourir
sortir ce soir etienne d'avant
mais m